I think you should be pretty easy this
is harder than that that I think my son
was trying to trick me I don't know this
is tough this one is Zeke's like you can
tell what it is but it's also kind of
sloppy Oh was it this one yeah oh that's
so funny the clock that my son has in
his bedroom has a digital clock so I'm
going to choose the only digital clock
of the bunch the one with the most color
on it this one the reason why is because
I know she knows what a clock is but I
don't think she knows where the numbers
ago
she's my keys the one that looks most
like a type of creature he likes to make
up is this one
this one feel like she will label also
the mixed colors I'm gonna say this one
and I don't really have a reason I just
think it is oh and you're gonna kill me
it's between these two
this one no oh my god I can't believe I
got it wrong I know I he can draw better
than this so I think he was trying to
trick me I will guess this one I'm gonna
say the green one because I think she
likes green apples more than real ones
this is really hard I think maybe this
one oh thank you I love you seek good
worm and Apple I am very surprised that
I got one of these wrong
the surprise is that he didn't try to
trick me I think he tried to use some
reverse psychology I kind of feel like I
was gonna know it threw me off to having
two kids at the similar levels is he did
throw me off a little bit on his
pictures I don't know if he did it on
purpose to try to trick me so that maybe
later on it could be like you know you
really hurt my feelings put some new
Pokemon cards it would really make up
for it I'm a little disappointed myself
I might buy some guilt Pokemon cards
after all oh man